what come to this video playing ground
Hawk play that's fun I never played him
before really thought I would have
remembered such a unique name but okay
yeah playing with the groundhog day
great movie but I'm i swear i'm not
going to sing i got you babe now okay
i'll set up my head shock here against
this as i normally do i think it's a
good way to play for win against this
opening keeps many pieces on the board
it asks the white player what what are
you going to do very often they don't do
anything and black might entertain ideas
to get in 'if I've come here black can
really make a ton of pre moves almost
sorry for the noise the bottle and oh he
allows me to take on f3 i'm going to do
that good or worse a good over us good
or bad I'm I want some imbalance here he
might be able to use the g file but i
still prefer to to have something going
on then just shuffling around all the
time so let's see how do i play here
though my plane night III get this get
this to f6 i wonder if i should go be
five before here at all
I don't know
yeah okay skin side is a bit of a rakia
but I cannot really exploited
yeah I don't mind this transformation f3
and then d5 that should be a good a good
porn structure for black at the end and
now if if I was hanging so you must
probably play a three
yeah then g6 and night g7 have five and
i have b 5 i'm going to start with B 5
and for a change I've been quick I
really wanted to click with clear ok so
is not moving it let's go be five then
now have a good bishop here the bishop
only seven is good in relation to the
pawns while his bishop is not very good
I wonder should I should he go before he
himself just blocking everything and no
okay so g6 maybe a five then remember
okay I need to play this anyway a five
is not the end of the world anyway f-5e
takes us 95 a funny situation with the
Queen on g 2 10 b7 before there was c4
that's a bit bit of a trick
yeah maybe maybe you move them no but ok
let's let's start with this fighting for
the a fall check
Queen a one may becoming a 1 B 1
something like that trying to infiltrate
before the right moment also would be
nice okay so my thinking was that you
can take on his six but this is not
necessarily so dangerous maybe it is
dangerous it's got to marry queen here
three nights you for coming
hmm
but I can go to see one maybe this is
right it keeps a many key squares
covered especially age 6 so what I'm
talking about is he takes a six place
okay he just shut it down decide didn't
didn't feel at all maybe wrongly I don't
know but this this doesn't fell didn't
feel any dangerous to me okay even
before yeah I mean he can you have to
check but I can dry I mean I can't
always take it so night age six is not
looking like it's it's it's it's since
any fatal Wow between before this night
h6 he saw that in one second young grade
here
maybe I can take with the bishop after
all but okay I can I can play this first
night h6 check is not not a problem
check yeah I take g3 check check check
so what's the easiest him shouldn't that
be some sort of least the Queen trade
it's somewhere check white wife and
silent on him reform its on time jan was
difficult even after taking on a three
whites position is not that bad but i
felt that this should be a good good
transformation of the whole thing yeah
maybe he should take on d5 an IG form
and now this this fields like black is
more comfortable i have the the ideas
now in the position with invasion on da
fall and long-term the better the better
structure in regards to the bishop now
computer OS gives me some advantage one
pawn 0.8 so it probably was okay Jim
took it bishop he once was good okay
yeah it here was a fun fun moment where
check this tactic was in the mix check
yeah this of course was blundering it
away he can play the smooth it looks
very passive but this is still ok for
what computer gives wieder nach here 0.5
or something that's hard to believe but
well yeah I don't have I don't have a
direct attack here I can't do something
like this but where it is leading where
exactly is it leading yeah the main
problem was I thought that I can always
get before back and i didn't i didn't
really something like this is stronger
should keep this option in the position
but don't play it right away this is
minus 2 ok thanks for watching